der marktanteil von bio lebensmitteln in
deutschland nimmt immer mehr zu
bio lebensmittel sollen besser sein für
das wohl der tiere als auch der natur
und obendrauf besser schmecken
gleichzeitig werde immer wieder kritik
darüber laut dass sich bio nicht lohnt
oder viel zu teuer ist oder es einfach
nicht genug auswahl geht also werde ich
mich eine woche ausschließlich von
biotopen er herausfinden ob es überhaupt
alles gibt was ich brauche wie gut die
qualität ist und vor allem wie teuer
meinte wocheneinkauf ist und auch wie
viel günstiger der gleich einkauft mit
nicht bio produkten gewesen wäre dieses
video geht unterstützt von einem
schnittkurs damit lernt man ganz schnell
alles was man für das schneiden von
youtube videos musik videos und
urlaubsvideos braucht uns daher aktuell
sowieso alle in quarantäne zu hause habt
ihr zeit und es gibt 33 prozent rabatt
mit dem kot hilfe machen wir gerade
gedanken darüber was ich diese woche
erst möchte ich werde zumindest
versuchen so ein bisschen durchschnitts
mäßigen einkauf zu erschaffen und ich
werde auch relativ viel kochen diese
woche gibst du zuerst pfannkuchen europa
sagte prof oder reibekuchen jedoch immer
mit ihnen polonaise darauf hätte ich
lust dann bist du nur mit hündchen
bisschen das leichtere aber dann ein
bisschen in laax käse und pro zum ersten
mal und gemüse pizza war geil ich selbst
gemacht das war richtig lecker
das geht so in die hose da ich kein
guter coach nun sogar vergessen hat was
genau in einem pfannkuchen drin ist
suche ich zu jedem gericht ein rezept
heraus und fertige dann eine
einkaufsliste an die ich in mein handy
übernehme anschließend geht es zum
einkaufen
ich kaufe genau das was auf meiner liste
steht die auswahl bei obst und gemüse
ist ziemlich groß und so finde ich
beinahe alles was ich brauche aber carlo
basilikum champignons kartoffeln
zwiebeln alles mit dem saftig grüne bio
siegel grüner spargel und frischem
meerrettich gab es leider nicht also
werden wir dafür später noch in einen
speziellen bioladen gehen auch bei
getrockneten früchten gibt es hier keine
bio variante aber das ist wohl die
korona haben es den käufern
zuzuschreiben hier der erste schock
selbst beim brot dem wofür deutschland
weltweit berühmt ist die bio auswahl
mickrig es gibt hier nur einen klumpen
aus roben vollkornbrot und einen
brüchigen pumpernickel zum glück wie
vorzüglich vollkornbrot aber ohnehin und
jeder weiß je schneller das große feld
desto gesünder ist nach einigen dingen
suche ich ewig andere dinge gibt es gar
nicht und auch bei der us mutter waren
wieder hamster amberg
wer in zeiten wie diesen hofft ein
großes nudel sortiment vor zu finden der
irrt außer er sucht bio vollkornnudeln
das zeug frist schauen wir wirklich
keiner alles in allem habe ich jedoch
dass meister gefunden und macht mich mit
einem dicken einkaufswagen gefüllt mit
bio produkten auf zur kasse wo ich
fahren werde wie teuer das ganze wird
aber dazu später mehr auf meiner
einkaufsliste sind noch immer einige
dinge nicht abgehakt wie zum beispiel
meerrettich getrocknete früchte
grüner spargel bandnudeln und brokkoli
ich betrete deswegen also zum
allerersten mal einen ausschließlichen
bioladen und ich bin verliebt der laden
ist riesig und hier gibt es scheinbar
alles bio süßlupinen goji beeren dinkel
gras und spirulina algen über alles was
man eben so braucht viel spaß beiseite
hier gibt es wirklich alles getrocknete
früchte finde ich sofort die
gemüseauswahl ist auch top auch wenn man
hier sieht dass die inneren werte
wichtiger sind als die äußeren
bandnudeln und curry sind auch kein
problem ich könnte mir sogar pistazien
im wert eines einfamilienhauses der
gesamtpreis bleibt vorerst geheim sonst
hättet ihr natürlich alle schon längst
abgeschaltet wird ich kann euch doch
aber die packung pistazien kostet soviel
sei verraten 310 euro 13 war auch etwas
ungesunde snacks gibt es hier eher sieht
alles etwas anders aus als die normalen
süßigkeiten die man so gewohnt ist doch
wahrscheinlich ist es genauso ungesund
aber im namen der wissenschaft schlage
ich auch hierzu und werde berichten
trotz einiger ironische bemerkungen
meinerseits finde ich den laden wirklich
stark die auswahl groß die qualität
macht einen guten eindruck und das
personal ist unfassbar freundlich so
etwas habe ich noch nie
noch nie in einem supermarkt erlebt da
eine meiner beiden packungen im grünen
spargels ihre besten tage leider bereits
hinter sich hatte bekomme ich diese
geschenkt das ist auch ziemlich gut denn
eine dieser packungen kostet fünf euro
90 ich bin endlich zu hause und fertig
mit dem einkaufen
es war wirklich anstrengend vor allem
diesen ganzen haufen herum zu schleppen
aber auch alles hier zu finden weil ich
viele sachen man ja weiß schon wo man be
ok findet keine ahnung das war alles aus
dem normalen supermarkt das war alles
aus dem speziellen biosupermarkt wir
sind ja dass der haufen viel viel größer
daher wie teuer die jetzt im vergleich
zueinander
dann wird auch spannend university ou
quasi aber auch spannend wird wie viel
das alles an meine gekostet hat und auch
spannend werden wie viel es kostet hätte
hätte ich nicht bio gekauft ursprünglich
wollte ich jetzt was cooles kochen mit
hühnchen hier und ein bisschen
bandnudeln da ich bin aber jetzt so
fertig dass es nicht einfach dazu
entschieden habe ein bisschen abendbrot
mit brot und lachs zu lassen doch wozu
habe ich jetzt eigentlich den fünffachen
preis für hefe gezahlt und was um alles
in der welt unterscheidet jetzt diesen
normalen zucker von diesem bio zucker
also optisch schon mal gar nix und
geschmacklich könig die beiden auch
unterscheiden der preisunterschied muss
sich also entweder im
herstellungsprozess oder aber im
geldbeutel des herstellers bemerkbar
machen und tatsächlich die gewinnmargen
bei bio produkten sind höher als bei
normalen lebensmitteln menschen sind
bereit mehr zu bezahlen für das
gütesiegel und das hat die wirtschaft
längst erkannt diese gütesiegel und
richtlinien bringen ja scheinbar auch
was aber was genau macht jetzt diesem
dem zucker so viel besser
ich frage einfach mal nach guten tag
thomas mein name mich würde jetzt
interessieren was dann genau einen bio
zucker so viel besser macht als einen
normalen zucker die frau am telefon hat
sehr freundlich auf meine fragen
reagiert und mich darüber informiert
dass bei bio zucker beziehungsweise den
zuckerrüben strenge von der eu
vorgeschriebene richtlinien eingehalten
werden müssen am ende hat sich mich noch
auf die webseite des herstellers
verwiesen wo es weitere informationen
gibt und sogar offen kommuniziert wird
qualitative unterschiede zu
konventionellem zucker gibt es nicht das
unternehmen macht auf mich tatsächlich
einen sehr transparenten und glaubhaften
eindruck und ganz ehrlich er kann zu ihm
schon nein sagen beim anbau von bio
zuckerrüben werden also ganz konkret
monokulturen welche die böden dauerhaft
schädigen vermieden es wird auf
schädliche pestizide verzichtet und auf
pflanzenvielfalt wert gelegt auch wenn
der zucker also nicht anders schmeckt
und genauso ungesund ist die umwelt und
in diesem fall ganz konkret die bienen
und andere insekten die weltweit
aufgrund von monokulturen und pestiziden
rapide absterben die werden davon
ziemlich deutlich profitieren aber
natürlich gibt es auch lebensmittel bei
denen bio auch geschmacklich einen
unterschied macht und das werden wir uns
jetzt ansehen das ist tatsächlich das
allererste mal dass ich koche seit
meinem
nämlich für einen euro pro tag gegessen
habe das stimmt so nicht ganz denn das
letzte mal habe ich in dem video gekocht
in dem ich in einer woche versucht habe
ich spanisch zu lernen
anschließend nach madrid geflogen bin
und mit echten spanien zu reden wenn ihr
wissen wollt ob ich mich da komplett
blamiert habe könnt ihr euch dieses
video gerne über den link in der video
beschreibung anschauen hier sind alle
zutaten die ich benutzen werde ich habe
mir zuerst überlegt ob ich nach rezept
kochen aber dann dachte ich mir nicht
mal noch mal drauflos wird bestimmt
lustig auf geht's
[Musik]
erst jetzt werde ich habe auch ein
bisschen die welt daran gemacht dass es
so viel verraten was ist daran gemacht
habe setzt du ja ja also ich bin es
richtig lecker ich hab das schon
probiert bevor ich in den ofen machen
das ist bitter also eine schüssel und
jetzt haben wir mehr ein
[Musik]
juli für stinkt genauso wie normale ich
dachte man macht ja sagt das doch ja
losgehen mit der kompletten hand rein
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich ihn gut der teig ist
gegangen
[Musik]
kann ich den teig dann auch zu drehen
wie ein echter italiener in der luft zu
wirbeln
ich werde probieren wo ist der paper
scissors entschuldigung gut dass erst
mal eine pizza ist deutlich dünner als
die von so viel also jetzt funktioniert
das bröckelt immer wieder voll viel ab
gab leider keine großen bio
[Musik]
[Applaus]
richtig geil ghana firma nächstes
gericht brauche ich also geht es nochmal
ab in den biomarkt das fleisch sei rein
optisch zumindest mal sehr gut aus und
ich denke fünf euro 50 44 100 gramm pro
renntag sind ziemlich fair
zum vergleich die selbe menge bio hat
gibt es beim discounter für drei euro 59
und ohne bio zertifikat sogar für zwei
euro 39 zwischen den einzelnen biosiegel
gibt es erhebliche unterschiede aber
natürlich garantiert selbst das
strengste biosiegel kein
umweltfreundliches und moralisch
lupenreines produkt nach lange köcheln
ist jetzt aus dass geworden nicht mehr
so ein flüssiges ling sonne und richtig
so rosig ist so klar das ist richtig gut
geworden
ich bin echt überrascht davon dass ich
einigermaßen gut kochen kann echt lecker
stark jetzt gibt's kartoffelpuffer oder
reibekuchen wie man die auch nennen wir
brauchen 15 kilogramm kartoffeln
mein arm eine große oder zwei kleine
zwiebeln die zwei eier
das war so viel mehl salz pfeffer
zusammenhatten puppe anbraten
[Applaus]
fertig also alles in allem finde ich die
sachen schon gut war natürlich ist auch
nicht das erste mal dass mit bio
gegessen haben es klar ich mag ich habe
es bei vielen sachen einen großen
unterschied geben gerade gemüse ist
tendenziell einfach besser und tomaten
gurken schmecken einfach nicht nach
wasser ist natürlich komplett
verständlich dass sich das nicht jeder
leisten kann also hier 129 und hier 229
bis jetzt schon relativ erheblich man
muss natürlich auch nicht alle produkte
in bio kaufen das ist vielleicht bei
manchen produkten noch drastischer als
bei anderen gerade wenn ihm die tiere
involviert sind jetzt mal ganz drastisch
gesehen hier bayern zum beispiel ist es
ja so dass die von kühn angelegt werden
so das problem ist nur weibliche bühne
legen eier
und deswegen wird er künftig für jede
legehenne auch ein männliches kind
geschreddert und bei den von demeter
hier zum beispiel nach nicht und das ist
ja schon mal relativ drastische
unterschied was aber auch aktuell noch
die wenigsten bio hersteller machen aber
die zum beispiel schon und darauf diese
brutal und wirtschaftliche entscheidung
die männlichen hühnchen nichts zu
schreddern wirkt sich natürlich auch auf
den preis aus aber der moment der
wahrheit wie viel hat sie kostet diese
haufen vom normalen supermarkt hat 112
euro gekostet was schon mal viel ist
aber für den ganzen wocheneinkauf was
waren wir jetzt vier tüten vier große
tüten ist schon teuer aber man muss auch
dazu sagen dass ich nicht auf den preis
sondern auch das hat deswegen gehe ich
davon aus er selbst wenn es nicht
gewesen wäre es trotzdem 70 oder 80 euro
gekostet hätte aber das sehen wir gleich
und der haufen hier der viel viel
kleiner ist als trotzdem ich mache in 48
euro gekostet davon aus dass diese
haufen den und biometra 20 euro gekostet
hätte und diese hoffnungen und bio so
ungefähr 70 euro insgesamt dann ebenso
90 eur 112 55 50 sind 167 und 50 euro
für eine woche oder 670 euro pro monat
das ist natürlich extrem viel denn der
durchschnittsdeutsche gibt gerade einmal
2 142 euro für lebensmittel aus pro
monat
die hohen kosten lagen natürlich nicht
nur daran dass ich bio gekauft habe
sondern auch daran dass dinge wie
pistazien lachs ananas pk nüsse und
avocados ohnehin sehr teuer sind der
gleiche einkauf für den ich also 167
euro 50 geteilt habe hätte ohne bio
produkte also immerhin noch 99 eur 47
also 398 euro pro monat bio hat also in
meinem fall 68 prozent mehr gekostet ich
bin mir aber sicher dass die auswahl der
lebensmittel eine höhere auswirkung auf
die kosten hat als die entscheidung ob
man bio ist oder nicht und ich bin mir
auch sicher dass man mit ausschließlich
bio produkten bequem günstiger als der
durchschnittsdeutsche essen kann wenn
man auf exotisches essen verzichtet und
selbst kocht meine freundin hat übrigens
ein video gemacht indem sie ein und
dasselbe sandwich einmal bio und einmal
nicht bio gemacht hat wenn ihr wissen
wollt ob ich den unterschied erkannt
habe habe ich ihr video in der video
beschreibung für euch verlinkt vor
einigen wochen habe ich versucht
innerhalb von einer woche mit einer app
spanisch zu lernen und bin danach sogar
nach madrid geflogen und habe mit echten
spanien geredet habe ich mich da
blamiert oder hat es geklappt liegt hier
wenn ihr das video anschauen wollt und
auf der anderen seite könnt ihr mich
abonnieren wenn ich auf dieser reise
begleiten möchte
[Musik]